[MUSIC PLAYING]
GABE WEISS: Hi, In
this video, I'll
introduce you to Datastream.
Then I'll walk through setting
up a stream from Oracle
to Cloud Storage.
I'm Gabe Weiss, a developer
advocate for Google Cloud.
Datastream is a serverless
Change Data Capture, or CDC,
and replication service.
Datastream makes it
easy to synchronize
data across heterogeneous
databases and applications
reliably and with
minimal latency.
Datastream provides a
simple, integrated experience
to guide you through
every step of the process.
It's serverless,
so you don't need
to worry about managing
or monitoring instances.
And continuous data
replication means
you can unify data
across multiple sources
and applications and make
it accessible in real time.
It helps power a wide
range of use cases,
including data replication for
analytics, database migrations,
event driven architectures,
AI and machine learning, data
lakes, and many more.
Whether your source
database is on premises,
self-hosted in Google Cloud,
or running on another Cloud,
Datastream helps
you quickly unlock
the benefits of real time CDC.
Now let's walk through
the Datastream experience.
You can easily find
Datastream by searching for it
in the Search box at the top
of the Cloud platform console.
You can also find it from the
Google Cloud console navigation
under Big Data.
To get started, you'll
create a stream.
This represents the
end-to-end process
of streaming changes
from your source database
to your destination.
First, let's define some basic
information about the stream.
I want to ingest data
from an Oracle database
I have running on GCE to a
Cloud Storage destination.
Once I've defined my source
and destination types,
Datastream shows me the
configuration required
for successful streaming.
Datastream is unique in that
it reflects all of the source
and destination
configuration requirements
directly within the
creation process
to take out the
guesswork involved.
For example, since I
chose Oracle as my source,
I can see the requirements
for setting up
the necessary login
configurations
and permissions on Oracle.
After confirming the
necessary prerequisites,
I'm ready to define my source.
I can do this by creating a
connection profile, a resource
that represents the
information needed
to connect to a database.
These profiles aren't locked
to an individual stream.
This means I can reuse
profiles if I want to,
and also allows me to hand
off creating the source
configuration to someone
else in my organization
who's in charge of
connecting to the database.
I've already created
a connection profile
for an Oracle database
running on Google Cloud's VM,
so I'll select it.
Whether I create my source
connection profile now
or use the one I
create in advance,
I can test connectivity
to make sure the data
stream is able to reach it.
Datastream supports both
public and private connectivity
methods to easily and
securely connect to sources,
whether they're hosted,
be it on Google Cloud,
on premise, or on
other Cloud providers.
Once the connectivity
test passes,
I can continue to configure
the stream for my source.
Next, I want to select the
objects that this stream should
pull from my source.
Using the selection
UI, can define
which schemas and tables to
stream from my Oracle source.
I will select the entire HR
schema and a couple of tables
from the movie schema.
For the objects I
selected, I also
need to bring over
the historical data.
So I leave the backfill
historical data enabled.
Now I'm ready to define the
destination for my stream.
Here again, I can create
a new connection profile
for my destination or
use an existing one.
I'll select the GCS
bucket I have ready to go.
Now, Datastream allows me to
specify a path within my Cloud
Storage bucket where the
streamed data will be stored.
For this demo, I want files
to be written to the root
folder of the bucket.
Datastream allows me to find the
right balance between file size
and data freshness that's
right for my use case.
It's important for me to have
my data available quickly,
so I'll reduce the writing delay
to destination to 15 seconds.
This means the files written
to GCS will be smaller,
but the data will
be available faster.
Well, that was easy.
I've connected and
configured my stream.
All that's left is to
validate the end-to-end stream
configuration and
start moving data.
Validation passed successfully.
I can trust that my
stream will run smoothly.
I'll create and start the
stream to run it immediately.
Once my stream is created,
I can monitor its progress
and see if it
encounters any issues.
Datastream will perform
the historical backfill
and continuously replicate
changes as they happen.
I can monitor different
metrics of the stream,
such as throughput,
latencies, and more.
That's it.
I've quickly and
easily shown you
how to continuously ingest
changes from an Oracle database
into Cloud Storage
using Datastream.
And since Datastream
is serverless,
it'll automatically scale up and
down to handle my data volume
and maintain minimal latency.
With change data now
continuously streaming
into Cloud Storage, I can
easily leverage products
like Dataflow to process
the data as needed.
For example, I
could use a purpose
built template to replicate
the data into BigQuery or Cloud
SQL for Postgres.
Datastream is the fast,
easy, and reliable way
to seamlessly
deliver change data
streams from your
database to Google Cloud
to support Analytics, database
replication, and event driven
architectures.
It's serverless, high
performance, and easy to use.
Now, it's your turn
to give it a try.
You can get started from the
Google Cloud console or learn
more at
cloud.google.com/datastream.
Thanks for watching.